I told you to expect in an eigenstate
into the James Comey hearings that uh we
tomorrow are expecting fired FBI
director James Comey to testify about
his conversations with Donald Trump and
it is starting so we've had the general
Twitter hysterics that we predicted but
Donald Trump has now scheduled a speech
that will take place
major coincidence Pat this is nothing
but a coincidence during James Comey
testimony tomorrow Donald Trump will be
speaking at the Faith and Freedom
Coalition Road two majority conference
at 12:30 p.m. Eastern time tomorrow
Thursday right in the thick of James
commis blockbuster testimony I'm sure
all media outlets will be covering
Trump's speech to the Faith and Freedom
Coalition rather than the fired FBI
director answering questions about
possible crimes committed by the
president right Dan I hope not Fox News
might but I still think most media
outlets are going to cover James Comey
CNN has at a countdown clock for the
past few days I feel like 48 hours when
I first saw ya I'm not going to just
change their programming schedule now
has there ever been Senate intelligence
panel testimony this anticipated where
CNN was running a multi-day countdown
clock I don't remember it if there has
been I don't know which committee Oliver
North testified to but I think that was
one of the ones that was highest-rated
in American history yeah but you'd have
to imagine that this is going to surpass
it whether or not it really deserves to
well I guess we won't know until after
after the hearing
president Trump has claimed that James
Comey told him three times that he was
not personally under investigation other
intelligence officials say that Donald
Trump asked James Comey to back off of
the investigation into now disgraced
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn what else are they doing well
according to a report from The
Associated Press the White House is
planning to undermine James commis
credibility White House officials are
going to be going after him over the
next couple of days
for missed statements he made about
Democrat Hillary Clinton's emails during
his last appearance on Capitol Hill
earlier I mentioned the Twitter part
that's going to be a factor Twitter will
be engaged for Trump Robert
Casta national political reporter for
The Washington Post stated on Twitter
quote I'm told by two White House
sources that President Trump does not
plan to put down Twitter on Thursday may
live tweet if he feels the need to
respond how embarrassing is it that the
President of the United States a 70 year
old man mind you will be taking time out
of what Sean Spicer says will be a full
and busy day for Trump tomorrow during
the Comey testimony to potentially live
tweet testimony about testimony from the
guy that he fired what a time to be
alive is and it is pretty crazy but at
least he didn't try to block James Comey
from testifying where parently he would
have had the authority to do yeah but
maybe they just thought that was a
bridge too far I mean you can fire the
guy that's investigating you but you
can't keep him silent and off the record
absolutely and by the way last time
Trump started live tweeting during Comey
testimony during the second part of the
testimony the tweets were brought up and
James Comey was able to dispel them as
totally false false notion so there's
also a risk to live tweeting for Trump
but we'll see what happens with that
I think Fox News will cover the Comey
testimony especially because they're
falling behind in the ratings I mean
they got to compete you know maybe so
yeah the Trump speech at the Faith and
Freedom Coalition is not exactly going
to drive in the ratings today's program
is made possible in part by Gamefly
which is sort of like netflix for video
games they've got over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can also stream games you don't
even need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the game
I think I mentioned that you can also
rent games through the mobile app get a
free 30-day trial for david pakman show
viewers and listeners and support our
show at Gamefly offer.com /t DPS